what are the common character archetypes
in comedy okay I can give you some
character types um but I I want to uh I
want to have a caveat
um that uh the the dangerous in thinking
of these archetypes as uh as characters
that you can utilize and push around
they're they're they're just slivers of
us right they're just they're just uh uh
fractions of our own psyche and our own
personality uh and you and you divide
them so as to help and storytelling for
instance
in friends yet the wise guy you have the
dits you have the mother you have the
the stupid guy uh and you have the nerd
and you have the um the Flirty Girl okay
now
why do you have those six
because
how would it be if you had two Wise Guys
well who are you gonna give the line to
okay you need to say you need somebody
to say something stupid
who do you want on stage who do you want
in the scene you want Joey in the scene
okay now you want somebody to be ditzy
but not stupid okay so let's bring
Phoebe on so the purpose of of utilizing
archetypes is not that you're you're
they're not stereotypes they are they
are representations of a certain point
of view of a certain way of way of being
and thinking but within the archetype
they're still people
so so you don't want to write them
exclusively as though they have no other
attribute
um
the you have
various kinds of of uh tricksters uh in
in Greek comedy
um
in Greek comedy uh there were
all sorts of different slave characters
and master characters and
what happens in Roman comedy is that
they did away with the 50-man chorus but
for Roman comedy they heightened the art
typical characters had been around since
early Greek time and then
after Roman comedy there's no comedy
because that's the Dark Ages and there's
no theater and there's no literacy and
there's no playwrights but they're still
actors
and so what do the actors do the actors
either act out scenes from The Bible or
they act out scenes using these archa
These are typical iconic characters the
clever tricky servant the uh dim uh
young man
the courtesan the bragged soldier all
these types were known to this these
traveling players who
were making things up improvising based
on character and situation
so
around the Renaissance you have this
theater form
that coalesces around characters called
the committee dollar and basically you
have an art form in which the character
stayed the same because they all wore
distinctive masks and tights so if you
saw the hook nose and the diamond tights
Ah that's Harlequin he's kind of like a
Charlie Chaplin mischievous Man Child
um like Kramer if Kramer comes through
the door you know exactly what you're
getting in Europe when the Harlequin
came out you knew exactly what you're
getting so you have these very specific
archetypes
so
what happens is is that there are no
playwrights there are no directors so
you have a situation in which the
character takes
the action
let's say you have two two um
young a young boy and a girl sitting on
a park bench what's their physical
motion they you know if they're both
young and good looking and not that
bright there you know they're going to
try to you know get together let's take
away the young man let's put in the
lecherous old man
uh the the you know what the the
pantaloni was was what he was called in
in the Comedia uh he could be a miser he
could be uh a hypochondriac uh he's
usually after the young girl so now
what's their physical movement
young girl lectures old man he's gonna
chase her around the bench right
so let's take away the young girl let's
put in the battle ax wife oh now what's
the movement now she's chasing him the
other way let's take them both away
let's put in three Zanies zany was a
term in the Comedia short for Giovanni
meaning
um there was the clever servant there
was the stupid servant there was the
compassionate servant
um all these different varieties of
stupid servants or clever tricky
servants they're all going to go in
different directions but they're because
they're idiots They're Gonna Knock heads
and knock each other out so the Comedia
teaches us that character creates plot
character creates action and character
creates movement so we we in turn we
then take this idea this actor-centric
idea
and in modern comedy
you have this same idea
these same characters
but the situation changes say on a
weekly basis
what does that sound like sounds like
sitcoms so so you have these are typical
characters you have
um uh you could have the fool you can
have the the wise guy you can have
um uh the uh the uh old you know the the
old man or the uh the the father but
that's only one way of
slicing and dicing because you can slice
and dice them any way you want any way
that makes sense the important thing is
not to have four of the same character
because you don't need for the same
character
um
uh you
uh there's there's there's a guy who
likes to see every cast as uh The Wizard
of Oz well who's our Dorothy who's our
tin man that's our uh our Cowardly Lion
other people use Winnie the Pooh okay uh
in in in Seinfeld uh Kramer's Tigger you
know the really bouncy one who's George
he's Eeyore
um so that so that it's less important
the uh there's a book out uh about the
the different character types in comedy
my my my preference is that
the only character that you absolutely
need in a comedy is a trickster you need
somebody who is going to bend the rules
color outside the box
you may have a fool in your in your cast
you may have a wise guy you may have
um a magical object of Desire what you
do have are blocking characters and
mirror characters blocking characters or
characters that are going to get in the
way of your main character maybe an
antagonist but doesn't necessarily have
to be
in Groundhog Day the insurance salesman
he's a blocking character
he he you know he's he's in the way and
eventually uh when Bill Murray realizes
there's no consequences for anything he
just punches him out he doesn't say a
word he just punches him out
and then you have mirror characters who
are your best friends
but
you only really and there are there are
uh rookie characters there's
um you know you know grizzled old vets
characters uh in in the comic heroes
Journey you have mentors mentors are
usually it you know idiots idiots who
have some knowledge in in the hero's
journey the mentors Obi-Wan Kenobi uh in
the comic heroes Journey the mentor is
the guy in DodgeBall who throws wrenches
at Justin Long's head because he says if
you can dodge a wrench you can dodge a
ball an idiot but still a mentor
character
but you'll but the only character that
you absolutely need is an archetype and
just know that that your your task is to
slice up personality and and your own
Humanity so that you don't have
duplications in your cast some other
characters that are essential in comedy
are the voice of reason oftentimes the
voice of reason is somebody that nobody
pays attention to or gives any credit to
uh in a lot of movies that's Jay
Baruchel uh who's actually in in Tropic
Thunder he's the one who's read actually
read the guidebook and can read a map
but nobody pays any attention to him
um but another important character is
the animal character uh a character
who's primal
you know Melissa McCarthy in in
Bridesmaids uh also Melissa McCarthy in
everything
um John Belushi in Animal House so
somebody who is
um going to uh act out of their Primal
urges and is very forceful and physical
about it uh your magical object of
desire that's usually the focus of
attention for your comic protagonist in
a rom-com with the Golden Girls
seemingly on the outside everybody
looked the same so you couldn't really
just by you'd have to watch the show to
figure out which one was the flirt which
one was the trickster which one was the
wise one right and and so but that took
time because they all look the same and
you thought but in writing it they knew
exactly how to write it because every
character had their function
not just their personality but they also
had their function so if you're going to
give somebody something sharp to say
you're gonna give it to the old person
right if you can give something somebody
something uh stupid to say
that's what Betty White was there right
uh-huh
or or yeah she was more the flirt yes
and was always bragging about all these
conquests and these different things and
then uh with um
sorry I'm liking on the name uh mod I'm
trying to think of it yeah she's she's
she's basically the Alex Rieger of that
Bunch you know you you often have a
father uh yes there's another friend of
mine who likes to think of every every
cast as a family who's the father who's
the mother who's the who's the weird
Uncle who's the uh the cousin you don't
like to talk to and he kind of divides
them like this